Ci sono ferite che non fanno rumore,
non arrivano come una porta sbattuta o
come una lite di quelle che si
raccontano agli amici davanti a un
caffè.
arrivano piano dentro casa, nel luogo in
cui avresti dovuto sentirti custodito. A
volte hanno la voce di un padre che
sminuisce tutto quello che fai, di una
madre che trasforma il senso di colpa in
un guinzaglio, di un fratello che sa
esattamente dove colpirti per farti
dubitare di te stesso. Ed è qui che
nasce una delle domande più difficili
anche per chi crede. Se la famiglia è
sacra, allora perché a volte è proprio
lì che l'anima si consuma? Io una
risposta netta ce l'ho, perché non tutto
ciò che è familiare è anche
spiritualmente sano e la Bibbia, se la
leggi senza romanticismi, non ti chiede
mai di restare dove vieni distrutto.
Molti sono cresciuti con un'idea quasi
intoccabile del legame di sangue, molto
italiana, molto nostra. È sempre tua
madre, è pur sempre tuo fratello. La
famiglia non si abbandona. frasi che
conosci bene perché da noi si sentono
nei pranzi della domenica, nelle cucine
piccole, piene di odore e di sugo, nei
salotti dove tutti sanno tutto di tutti,
ma nessuno nomina il vero problema.
Eppure [musica]
la scrittura non idolatra il sangue,
mette al centro la verità.
Gesù stesso nel Vangelo spezza
l'ipocrisia affettiva quando dice che
chi ama padre o madre più della verità
non è degno di seguirlo.
È una frase che scandalizza perché
smonta l'educazione sentimentale con cui
molti sono stati addestrati.
Ma il punto è chiarissimo. Dio non
benedice i vincoli che ti allontanano
dalla tua dignità, anche se hanno il tuo
stesso cognome. Il primo modo in cui Dio
ti allontana da persone tossiche spesso
non è esterno, ma interiore. Prima
ancora di cambiare le circostanze cambia
il tuo stomaco, il tuo sonno, la tua
pace. cominci a sentire un peso prima di
una telefonata, una stanchezza strana
dopo una visita, una confusione che
arriva puntuale dopo certe
conversazioni.
C'è chiama tutto questo sensibilità
eccessiva. Io penso invece che molto
spesso [musica] sia discernimento.
Nella Bibbia la pace non è solo
un'emozione dolce, è anche un criterio
spirituale.
Quando una relazione ti svuota sempre,
ti umilia sistematicamente,
ti obbliga a tradirti pur di mantenere
una tregua apparente, non sei davanti a
una croce da sopportare, sei davanti a
una dinamica da riconoscere. E sì, lo
dico con convinzione, molti credenti
chiamano amore ciò che in realtà è
dipendenza travestita da dovere. Poi
accade una cosa sottile ma decisiva. Dio
[musica] inizia a farti vedere quello
che prima giustificavi.
Ti rendi conto che non sei stato troppo
per maloso, sei stato allenato a
sopportare troppo. Ti accorgi che quella
battuta non è stata ironia, ma disprezzo
ben confezionato.
che quel lo dico per il tuo bene era
controllo, che quel continuo ricordarti
i sacrifici fatti per te non era
affetto, era debito emotivo. In Proverbi
si legge che sopra ogni cosa bisogna
custodire il cuore perché da esso sgorga
la vita.
Non dice di offrirlo a chiunque, non
dice di lasciarlo aperto a chi lo
calpesta, non dice di sacrificare la tua
salute mentale per non deludere chi ti
manipola. Custodire il cuore a volte
significa chiudere una porta con dolore
ma senza odio. Un altro modo in cui Dio
ti separa è che smette di farti
funzionare nei vecchi ruoli.
Il pacificatore della famiglia, il
figlio che comprende sempre, quello che
assorbe tensioni per evitare esplosioni,
quello [musica] che mette una pezza a
tutto. A un certo punto non ce la fai
più e non sempre è una caduta. A volte è
una liberazione. Elia, Mosè, Davide.
Nella Bibbia perfino i forti hanno avuto
momenti in cui non riuscivano più a
sostenere tutto. Perché?
Perché Dio non ti crea per essere il
sistema nervoso di una casa
disfunzionale.
Se ogni volta che torni da certi parenti
ti senti come dopo una maratona emotiva,
forse non sei tu che stai sbagliando,
forse hai smesso di recitare la parte
che teneva in piedi un equilibrio falso.
E c'è anche un segnale che molti
ignorano. Dio manda nuove persone e il
contrasto ti sveglia. incontri qualcuno
che ti parla con rispetto e
improvvisamente capisci quanto eri
abituato alla durezza. Vivi un'amicizia
pulita e allora noti quanto fosse
tossico quel clima in cui l'amore
arrivava sempre con una puntura.
[musica]
In chiesa, nel lavoro, in una
conversazione semplice con qualcuno che
non ha bisogno di dominarti, [musica]
scopri che non devi guadagnarti il
diritto di esistere. Questo è
potentissimo perché spesso Dio non ti
illumina solo mostrandoti il [musica]
male, ma facendoti assaggiare il bene. E
quando assaggi il bene vero, il
surrogato affettivo non ti basta più.
Qui però non tutto si risolve con il
dialogo. So che oggi va di moda dire
parlane, spiegati meglio, comunica con
calma.
Va bene finché dall'altra parte c'è una
coscienza disposta ad ascoltare, ma con
chi manipola, nega, ribalta i fatti e
usa la tua apertura come materiale
contro di te, il dialogo infinito
diventa autosabotaggio.
Anche Gesù davanti a certe chiusure
taceva o si allontanava, non inseguiva
tutti, non si lasciava trattenere da
tutti.
Questa idea che una persona spirituale
debba restare sempre accessibile,
disponibile, raggiungibile e morbida con
chiunque, secondo me, ha fatto più danni
di quanto vogliamo ammettere.
La bontà senza confini nelle mani
sbagliate diventa carburante per
l'abuso. Ed è qui che entra una verità
che sorprende molti. L'allontanamento
non è sempre un castigo, a volte è una
risposta.
Ci sono porte che si chiudono, litigi
che portano distanza, trasferimenti
improvvisi, lavori che cambiano,
relazioni che si raffreddano e tu
inizialmente pensi che sia tutto rotto.
Poi col tempo capisci che proprio quel
distacco ti ha restituito lucidità.
Nella Bibbia Abramo deve lasciare la
casa di suo padre per entrare nella sua
chiamata.
Giuseppe viene separato violentemente
dalla sua famiglia e pur in modo
dolorosissimo quel distacco apre una
traiettoria che altrimenti non avrebbe
mai visto. Questo non significa
romanticizzare il dolore, ma riconoscere
che Dio a volte ti salva anche
disinnescando la vicinanza. Se ti è
successo scrivimelo nei commenti. Magari
una distanza che all'inizio sembrava una
perdita. col tempo si è rivelata una
protezione. A questo punto un consiglio
che reputo prezioso è questo: smetti di
misurare la bontà di una relazione dai
momenti belli e inizia a misurarla dai
suoi effetti ricorrenti.
Anche le relazioni tossiche hanno
parentesi tenere.
È proprio questo che le rende confuse.
Un familiare può abbracciarti a Natale e
distruggerti a febbraio, [musica] può
aiutarti economicamente e poi usare
quell'aiuto come una cambiale morale per
anni.
In Italia questa ambiguità si vede
spesso in famiglie dove il favore
diventa controllo. Ti do una mano con la
casa, con il lavoro, con i figli, però
poi mi devi accesso, obbedienza,
silenzio, ma l'amore sano non ti
presenta il conto. Un criterio adulto,
quasi clinico, è osservare i pattern,
non gli episodi. Se una persona alterna
carezza e dominio, non sei davanti a una
contraddizione innocente, sei dentro un
ciclo. Un altro consiglio più
sorprendente di quanto sembri è non
spiegare troppo la tua guarigione a chi
trai vantaggio dalla tua ferita.
Quando Dio ti porta fuori da certe
dinamiche, nasce in te il desiderio di
essere finalmente compreso. È umano, ma
non sempre è saggio. Chi ti controllava
spesso non vuole capirti, vuole solo
recuperare accesso. Per questo i confini
migliori sono semplici, brevi,
ripetibili.
Non servono a ringhe, servono frasi
pulite e coerenti.
Di questo adesso non parlo,
oggi non posso venire.
Se mi alzi la voce chiudo la
conversazione.
Sembra poco spirituale, io penso il
contrario. La chiarezza [musica] è una
forma di verità e la verità nella Bibbia
libera, non intrappola in trattative
infinite. C'è poi una dimensione più
profonda che raramente viene detta
[musica] abbastanza.
Separarti da un contesto tossico può
farti sentire in colpa prima di farti
sentire libero.
È normale. Il senso di colpa è spesso il
sintomo dell'antico addestramento, non
la prova che stai sbagliando. Se per
anni sei stato educato a confondere
l'amore con la disponibilità totale,
appena metti un confine ti sembrerà di
essere diventato cattivo. Ma non sei
cattivo, stai disimparando una
distorsione.
Paolo scrive che Dio non ci ha dato uno
spirito di paura, ma di forza, amore
[musica] e disciplina.
Ecco, la disciplina emotiva è anche
questo, non tornare subito dove sei
stato ferito solo perché ti manca la
familiarità.
Non tutto ciò che ti è familiare ti fa
bene. A volte persino la gabbia dopo
tanto tempo sa di [musica] casa. E
voglio dirti una cosa da donna con
sincerità. Alcuni familiari non
cambieranno solo perché tu finalmente
hai pianto, pregato, spiegato,
perdonato, aspettato. Questa è una delle
verità più dure da accettare, ma anche
una delle più liberanti. Tu puoi
cambiare posizione, puoi cambiare
accesso, puoi cambiare la geografia del
tuo cuore. Non sempre puoi cambiare
[musica] chi ha scelto di restare cieco.
La fede autentica non è negare la realtà
per sembrare buono, è guardarla in
faccia senza perdere l'anima. E secondo
me una delle maturità spirituali più
alte è smettere di chiedere a chi ti ha
sempre dato briciole il pane che solo
Dio e talvolta persone nuove possono
offrirti.
Alla fine forse il segno più chiaro che
Dio ti sta allontanando da qualcuno
[musica] è che smetti di chiamare pace
ciò che in realtà era semplice assenza
di conflitto.
La vera pace non ti rimpicciolisce, non
ti costringe a filtrare ogni parola, non
ti fa vivere in allerta come se dovessi
prevedere il prossimo scatto, la
prossima colpa, la prossima umiliazione
elegante detta con il sorriso.
La vera pace ti restituisce respiro,
presenza, capacità di pregare senza
sentirti sporco, lucidità nel dire sì e
dignità nel dire no. Se questo messaggio
ti ha toccato, raccontami nei commenti
qual è stata la prima volta in cui hai
capito che mettere [musica] distanza non
era tradire la tua famiglia, ma smettere
di tradire te stesso.
E se vuoi continuare questo percorso con
noi, iscriviti a Dose Mentale. Qui non
siamo mai alla ricerca di frasi comode,
ma cerchiamo verità che ti guariscano
davvero. Ci vediamo nel prossimo